clapping ce matin devant le chu des
employés du chum toujours mobilisés
contre la présence des gendarmes et de
policiers devant les entrées de leur
établissement des forces de l'ordre
venues aider les agents de surveillance
à contrôler les passes sanitaires et
pour les syndicalistes cette situation
n'est pas acceptable
ils refusent de travailler sous le
contrôle de la police ou des gendarmes
c'est à dire que nous avons prévu de
faire un mouvement d'ensemble d'ici la
semaine prochaine avec martinique
guadeloupe guyane
marqué notre mécontentement et notre
détermination contre l'obligation
vaccinale le pass alité 1 le même jour à
la même heure et devant les
établissements s'adonnent au chu de
martinique chu de guadeloupe où
l'hôpital de cayenne à ce qui est prévu
dans l'immédiat nous n'allons pas lâcher
parce que n'est pas normal que nous
soyons des gendarmes pour recevoir alors
que nous n'avons commis aucune faute et
nous voyons qui a encore dit le jeune
homme qui est arrivé alors que le préfet
n'a pas assumé ses responsabilités en
une caserne de gendarmerie
donc ça c'est un phénomène inhabituel
inacceptable ce ne sont pas les seuls
j'entends qu'on voit derrière nous il y
en a partout donc aujourd'hui on peut
considérer qu'on a transformé un
établissement de santé en établissement
de guerre avec des gendarmes en milieu
de matinée seuls les entrées annexe de
l'hôpital étaient libres d'accès pour
les patients le personnel la
mobilisation de l'intersyndicale se
poursuit les syndicalistes refusent
l'application du pass annie terre pour
le personnel
temps